[Music]
who can resist the legend of Bigfoot
stories have circulated for years of the
Yeti small foot is the story of yetis
seeking to prove the existence of humans
and the cast is star-studded if this is
your first time visiting the things hit
that subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up let's jump right
into the voices behind this small foot
movie a monster the movie small foot is
the heart-melting story of Mego the Yeti
Mego can't shake the feeling that the
legendary humans are real he and his
friends are obsessed with proving that
small foot is out there Mego gets his
wish and stumbles upon a human in the
wild his community doesn't know what to
believe so they banished poor amigo
until he can find proof Miko does what
any sensible Yeti would do he travels
far away to a human village and finds a
small foot to take home the to go on a
wild adventure we're both creatures
learn about each other the movie already
sounds really awesome doesn't it what
more could you want in a hilarious plot
and a fun spin on an old story how about
a cast full of incredible talent small
foot is voiced by some of the biggest
celebrities around let's take a look at
the famous voices that make up this
awesome cast Channing Tatum as MIGO
Channing Tatum voices the curious Mego
Jane is a megastar with films like the
lego movie and 21 Jump Street under his
belt he's been in over 50 full-length
movies so chances are you'll recognize
his voice right away
Chanin has had a celebrated career
winning dozens of awards he's one of
people's choice kids toys teen toys and
several MTV Movie Awards it's loud and
clear people love him
we can't wait to hear how he plays a
Yeti who's afraid of humans
zendaya as Michi joining me go in this
epic story are many friends one of whom
is voiced by supermodel was India
zendaya was born in California and began
modeling as a kid she worked for Macy's
Old Navy and Mervyn's before she broke
into acting she got her big break on the
Disney Channel show shake it up as the
character rocky blue she was also a
contestant on Dancing with the Stars she
really became a household name after her
appearance in the greatest showmen
Scindia isn't just a talented actor and
singer she's also an author and has
launched her own clothing line that's a
ton of talent for one person that is
where we come in LeBron James as Gwangi
this cast really is impressive LeBron
James joins as blonde G miss Judith this
Laker star may be best known as an
athlete but this isn't his first acting
gig he's taken to the sound booth to
lend his voice to episodes and spongebob
squarepants and Teen Titans go he's been
in front of the camera too and
box-office hits like trainwreck it's
been announced that he'll also have a
role in the upcoming Space Jam sequel to
LeBron is a talented and funny guy who
is sure to add some awesome personality
to small foot James Corden as Percy as
crucial as the yetis are to the story
the elusive human may be the real star
James Corden plays the voice of Percy
please nobody's watching my show the
human Mego borrows Percy's character
used to be on TV in the story so we're
sure he's got a lot of personality James
Corden is an excellent choice to play
Percy as he's hosted talk shows in real
life he's also voiced characters in the
trolls and the emoji movie James has
acted in feature films starred in
episodes of Doctor Who and written
dozens of scripts he's hilarious and
charming so were hyped to see Percy come
to life
Gina Rodriguez as coca adding another
huge name to the list is Gina Rodriguez
Gina is a Chicago native and a hugely
successful actor she's been credited as
a writer director editor cinematographer
and more
that's all in addition to over 40
credits as an actor Gina likes to stay
bust and knows every part of the film
industry she's performed as a salsa
dancer and is also involved in the
Hispanic scholarship fund she provides
the voice of coca in small foot and
she's sure to nail it common as stone
Keeper there's another famous Chicago
native on the cast list - rapper common
will play the role of stone keeper legal
you will be banished from the village
common began his career as a musician
then broke into acting he has over 60
credits to his name now he's still got a
thriving music career and is working on
his seventh album common has acted in TV
shows feature films and animation before
he's a seasoned pro so stone keeper is
sure to be so much fun to watch Danny
DeVito as door gold
Danny DeVito may have the most extensive
resume of the entire small foot cast
with over 130 credits to his name
he's been acting directing and writing
for decades Danny is a comedy genius he
was the voice of the Lorax in the recent
animated film and stars in is Always
Sunny in Philadelphia you may recognize
him as Matilda's awful car salesman dad
in small foot all of that talent and
years of experience
ringed Oracle to life we can't help but
love doggles moustache with such an
incredible actor behind this character
he's sure to be as hilarious as his
facial hair Yara Shahidi as Brenda Yara
Shahidi lends her distinct voice to the
movie - she's been winning hearts and
fans in her sassy role on the TV show
blackish this Minneapolis native is more
than a talented actor she's also
brilliant the high school sophomore is
studying persian and plans to become a
historian talent runs in Yaris family
she's first cousins with rapper Nas
Jimmy Tatro as store
YouTube star Jimmy Tatro will also
appear in the film
this isn't Jimmy's first acting role off
of the streaming site the actor has more
than 20 credits to his name
he's even worked with Channing Tatum
before on 22 Jump Street we're sure the
two of them are excited to work with
each other again after his online
success showing the world his life as a
college student
Jimmy broke into acting his first role
was a minor character in grownups too
that tiny part has led to appearances on
TV shows as well as more feature film
roles
we're pumped to see what he does with
the character Thorpe those are just a
handful of the towns of people who made
this film possible turning this classic
tale of myth and mystery on its head is
a unique idea Hollywood has recently
taken flack for releasing too many
sequels and reboots we're excited about
this fresh idea we're excited to see so
many huge names in the credits there's
so much talent behind this film we hope
you enjoyed taking a peek behind the
scenes of small foot we'll see you next
time
[Music]